Me again. You know, you gotta set yourself
up for success, alright. And LingQ makes
that easier, because everything you do on
the computer is synced with your mobile
device, and so you can review your LingQs
on your mobile device, you can listen on
your mobile device. What you should do,
you should make sure that you create
playlists for the lessons that you're
studying so that you can listen wherever
you are. And the playlist also tracks how
often you listen, so that this is also
motivating that you know that you've
listened 10, 20 times so the same content,
still have trouble understanding it, but
it's all putting this into your mind.
There's so many periods of so called
"dead time" during the day when you can
listen, or review flashcards, or even read
your lessons on your mobile device. So
take advantage of all the features at
LingQ and how it works across different
platforms to ensure that you succeed in
your language learning.